He said he doesn't look offcreen to read script. He has a sticky
note saying be confident and it helps him. Okay. And that's what
got me started on this. Sorry to interrupt your live stream and
everything. But I was just hoping to ask you a few questions.
Questions about bronies in particular if you don't mind.
We've actually met before. I wanted to ask you some question.
So every time he looks off camera he's just looking at a sticky
note that says be confident. Okay. Got it. Got it. Be confident.
a measure of man card posting video on cuz I know card posting
doesn't post long videos, right? Card posting very short videos.
Oh, I don't think I watched this with you guys. Did you guys
watch the uh the null video he did? The card posting video on
on null that he did. We should watch that. Okay, we should watch
that. It's probably quite a bit back. Yes, this one. I watched
this.
This was such a good video. It's three weeks ago. I think I was
like I was back in my um my hometown. I was sitting in like a
parking lot. I had to wait like three hours in a parking lot.
And this was something I watched while I was sitting in that
parking lot. Okay. And if you guys didn't watch it, if you guys
don't know if you don't know who Card Posting is, he's like a
guy who used to make videos about dog whistles. Okay? That's
what his videos were. They were about dog whistles. All right?
Like right-wing dog whistles. That's what his content was. But
uh he just does like other random
political videos. I don't know. I don't know. This guy's like
he's like an enigma. But he came out and he put out a video on
Josh Moon and Kiwi Farms. Okay.
Or car posting. I don't think so. I don't think he did that.
Here we go. Here we go. Uh I maybe pause the music for this.
Ah, Mr. Moon. Hello there. Sorry to interrupt your live stream
and everything, but I was just hoping to ask you a few questions.
Questions about bronies in particular, if you don't mind.
Take a long. We've actually met before.
My name's Lieutenant Card Lumbo. See? Uh,
see here.
This is my wallet. It's empty because I'm actually a longtime
progressive organizer and activist. May I uh sit down? Thank
you.
This guy's like a different universe's President Sunday. Okay.
He's like he's just uh he's got like an aura about him that is
very unique. See, uh I don't know if you've all seen him before.
I don't know how much you guys are familiar here on my YouTube
page recently. I've been trying to uh stir up drama by antagonizing
groups of people.
I'm just uh not very good at it, though. I need a few pointers.
So, I figure I should come to you for that. That's He had like
shorter hair for a while and he just keeps having like his like
hairline keeps getting worse and his hair keeps getting longer
and I don't know. It's uh
area of expertise after all.
See, uh I read your file. It's very impressive, sir. Running
that uh Kiwi Farms was it for uh 12 years now. I got to figure
you're the best when it comes to online
Now, see, you and I, I bet we don't share a lot of politics,
but I do agree with you on one thing for
I don't think
some fandoms are all that respectable. I think there are a few
out there. They're a bit off the deep end.
I just don't like
he said he doesn't look offcreen to read script. He has a sticky
note saying be confident and it helps him. Okay. And that's what
got me started on this bronies thing. I wanted to ask you some
question. So every time he looks off camera, he's just looking
at a sticky note that says be confident. Okay. Got it. Got it.
Because these bronies
these are grown men who are obsessed with a cartoon for little
girls.
They are be confident be confident
measure of a man by his interests and I for one wouldn't shake
the hand of any man who considers himself a fan of My Little
Pony
so
I want to do something of an expose
on these people.
There might be some
I didn't know. So, I was unaware of the lore that Josh Moon's
apparently a prolific brony. Is this just known? Do people just
know this?
Why? How? Why would you share that information with people even
among us? Don't you know? So, what I want to know is how best
to identify these guys so we can get it out of society.
A noble goal. I'm sure we can agree on that at least. So, that's
what I wanted to ask you. I was wondering if there's anything
at all you could tell me about
cuz uh see I've been trying to dig up as much information about
these guys as I can. Earlier today I went through your kiwi farms
and I took a good look around. Don't worry about it. I'll make
sure to get a warrant for all that later. But I'm coming to you
now because what I found was very interesting.
Or rather, sir, you might say it's what I didn't finish the card
posting. What I'm trying to wrap my head around is there's surprisingly
little about bronies
on kiwi farms.
I just didn't think that would add up.
I mean, I saw pages and pages making fun of weeaboos and tankies
and fatties and every other type of manchild out there.
But I you can tell he's a progressive organizer because he did
not mention trans people at all. Kiwi Farms obviously a large
penant for mocking trans people. Didn't even mention it. Got
to be a progressive organizer. Very little about bronies comparatively
speaking. Of course,
it seems like plenty of users there don't like them. Can't say
I'd blame anyone for thinking that either. But in terms of what
you yourself have posted, what threads you've facilitated about
him, there's very little.
I guess that's okay. I mean, I only came down here to see if
there's anything about him you could tell me to uh help me with
my expose and everything. But uh I guess if you just don't know
enough about him to make fun of them yourself,
that's just how it is. These things can't be helped.
It's uh probably for the best anyway if you don't want to go
getting mixed up with these pony people. It's not a good crowd.
You know, just last week I made a video talking about how there's
far too many horse on the internet nowadays.
And the worst part of it is they always try to cover it up and
pretend. Is that is that is that a Vosch reference? I feel like
that's a Vos shot right there. be normal even after they're exposed.
Anyway, that's all I came down here to ask. I'll get out of your
hair.
Just one more thing.
It's nothing, but see, most of my work here on YouTube is doing
my daily the dog whistle videos.
It's not much, but it's honest content
Of course, I couldn't make all those entirely on my own. See,
I got boys back at the lab. They scour the entire You actually
find this funny? I do find this very funny. I find this tremendously
funny.
I might be mentally ill. Okay. I find this tremendously funny.
Unironically,
always looking for new stuff for me to investigate.
And they told me you recently did a reaction to my video about
Deans. That was your uh April 4th show, I believe. Well, I got
to admit, I like to hear what people are saying about me. So,
I went and watched your April 4th Mad at the Internet. But, see,
I'm not good with computers. Look, all these ones I've got, they're
just collecting dust. I don't know how to use them at all. So,
uh, I couldn't figure out how to skip to just the part where
you were talking about my Dean video, so I had to watch the whole
thing. It was good stuff. So, like I said, I'm all for antagonizing
people online myself now.
But uh before I got to the part I was there for, you did a segment
making fun of some uh gross failed slob or another as well as
the people who spring to his aid online.
Like I said, there's really no idea who he's talking about. All
good. All good. But the thing that caught my eye, you made a
very particular remark about someone's
Twitter profile pick here. Uh
I've actually got it on tape. This is your uh April 4th mad at
the internet right here. Let me just uh pop it in my machine
and we'll take a look.
Um okay, let's talk about Ralph a little bit. Uh there's not
much to talk about with Ralph. He just posted this. He says,
"It's been fun and perspectivity. I love you like a brother even
though you're gay. You really think a loser like that can do
what I do?" Okay. Oh, no. Sorry. It's not. Those were not. I
thought those were posted at the same time. Ralph just randomly
posted two hours after he had a gay breakup with his boyfriend
versus Picassid that uh it's been fun. And a lot of people are
like, "No, Ralph, don't do it. Don't do it, Ralph. Look, this
guy is a Derpy Hooves My Little Pony fan in 2025, our year of
the Lord, and he's begging Ethan Ralph to not commit."
Now, sir, when I heard that, I couldn't make heads or tails on.
You said that picture is a derpy hooves, I believe. Now, see,
I'm 25. I'm a grown man. I don't know what that means.
Luckily, my wife, Mrs. Card Lumbo, well, she knows this stuff.
She's the same age as me. So, on account of her having been a
10-year-old girl in 2010, she knows this My Little Pony stuff.
Makes sense. That's about the only reason. That's like uh that's
where I realized that I'm not a
That's where I realized that uh I'm old as well. Okay. She was
10 years old in 2010. Oh, no. What?
That's
None less. Oh, wait. No, it's not. She tells me this Derpy Hooves
is a My Little Pony character. And not just any character, but
a fairly out of the way background character at that. So, I just
got to ask her, is there any reason you can apparently recognize
Rare Ponies on
Josh, are you maybe a little more intimately familiar with the
show than your He's only 25. No, his girlfriend's only 25. He
might be significantly older. He's a progressive organizer. He
could be 50 for all we know. I He doesn't look 50, but we're
letting on. Oh, he's doing Columbbo. Yeah. Did you You didn't
pick up that he was doing Columbbo when he said, "I'm Lieutenant
Card Lombo."
One togover. Are you even paying attention?
Are you even attempting to pay attention? Yes. He said, "I'm
Lieutenant Card Lombo." He flipped open his wallet and said,
"This is my wallet. It's empty."
Okay. Have you perhaps used your operatorship of Kiwi Farms to
stifle people from making as much fun of the show and its fandom
than they would otherwise? You know, I used to follow the Chris
Chan stuff myself once upon a time. And I noticed you always
used to give Chris plenty of and rightfully so for the excessive
game buying and the toys and the living at home. But I can't
recall you ever specifically saying a bad thing about Chris directly
for the brony stuff. Why is that? Would it maybe cut a little
too close to home?
Mr. Moon, have you ever been diagnosed with autism? What I'm
saying is, are you secretly a brony? Cuz I think you are. And
I think this will all stand up perfectly well in the court of
public opinion, too.
Now, I hate to do this in front of your Yes. So his allegation
is Josh Moon actually hides
okay actually hides criticism of bronies actually stifles criticism
of bronies because he himself is a brony. Now I don't know I
don't know what legitimacy there is to this but it isn't tremendously
funny to watch him lay it all out. Okay fans I really do. It
just is. But since it seems like I might have caught you in something
embarrassing here. How about you make your confession now? And
it' save the fellas over at the base department a lot of time
figuring out whether it needs to be wall or rope this
Hold on. Hold on. You I don't know if you guys cut the face now.
Whether or not it needs to be wall or rope this time. Hold on.
The smile is good. Okay.
Why don't you make your confession now and save us the the discussion
of whether or not it's going to be uh Waller rope this time.
Boom. Boom.
Yeah, it's uh he's like a tiny channel and he's calling out Josh
Moon, right? It's just it's funny. It was a funny video. I like
the video when it came out, but again, I watched it by myself
in a parking lot. I don't think I ever brought it up on stream.
So, that's card. Okay, now we got a card video. You should hate
Pirate Software.
You should hate Pirate Software. We're going to watch this and
then we will get on to the kickstreamy stuff. Okay. Hello there.
My name's Card and here on my YouTube page, I like to make simple
little videos about things that cross my mind. Today, I just
want to briefly articulate some thoughts on a topic I've tangentially
brushed up against before,
but it's something that might need to be restated unabashedly
at this point.
You should hate pirate software.
Realistically, if you're You should if you if you understand
anything about the internet, if you dislike people who are
narcissistic and have no hope of ever fixing themselves, you
should hate private software. Watching this, you already know
who that is. Internet commentator, live streamer, and ostensibly
games developer Jason Thor Hall. Ostensibly, and today I just
want to ostensibly for the sake of anyone who might still need
to hear it.
Now, how does he compress this into four minutes? Why you should
hate Pirate Software in four minutes?
That would be impressive. You shouldn't just merely dislike the
man or simply disagree with his
You should hate him and everything he stands for and represents.
I don't necessarily want this video to be just a laundry list
of everything bad he's ever done. Not just because that would
be a very long list, but because that would only be half a point
anyway.
Sure, you could mention Pirate Softwware's years and years of
based off his nepo hire do nothing former job or how he treats
literally everyone he
dude collaborated to fans with absolute condescension and contempt.
Or you could mention how most recently he's inserted himself
into a consumer rights campaign to just be a fict columnist wrecker,
lie a whole bunch about the movement itself, and refuse to apologize
for what he's done. You could mention all that, but I won't because
you shouldn't have to keep track of every single thing someone
like this has done. It doesn't need to be your job or my job
to maintain a complete record of every single slimy thing someone
else has done.
All you need to keep in mind is that he's worth hating.
You know it, I know it.
It's not discreet actions here and there or being assigned. How
did Pirate ever keep a job with that sort of mental illness?
Uh his dad worked at Blizzard for one thing. His dad was like
a very wellrespected member of Blizzard. Okay. Or contributor
at Blizzard. And
um I don't know most most places you could keep a job especially.
It depends on what the like overall economy is like. At a lot
of places, if you're contributing at all, you'll be able to keep
a job
that badness point and getting weighed up at the end of the day
to see if someone's a good person or not.
It's not what he has done and keep doing. It's just his personality,
his motivations, what pirate software is at the core of his being.
this greedy, lying, antisocial little wretch.
People like this are always worth hating. The narcissists, the
bloiators,
the people who try to lord industry connections from being on
the computer all day over you, as if that makes them better people.
These people who choose to argue against the public interest
because of their own shortsighted greed. Oh, this is uh the stop
games reference. They're scum. Yeah. And you're allowed to think
it's good when they finally get some semblance of push back or
comeuppance for their actions.
There's some people out there in the world who think it's just
inherently wrong or regressive or childish to hate people or
to rail against public figures online or whatever. And those
people are wrong. Wrong. and just trying to run cover for all
the other people in the world who deserve criticism.
When do you find someone who like Pirate Software deserves all
the hate they're getting and much much more?
Encourage that hate. Feed it. Remind yourself and others that
it's perfectly okay,
good even, to wish all the worst in the world on this guy and
people like him.
The pirate software hates you. He has nothing but contempt for
anyone he sees as below him. Which we're nearly at the end of
the Pirate Software hate video. People who don't watch him, all
the other creators online who he's lied about or lied to or tried
to attack through legal means maliciously and wrongly.
And I guess he even hates all the people closest to him too,
who he once called friends. given our pirate software simply
acting during his buddy's game night is what started getting
people to take a closer look at what else he gets up to anyway.
And if pirate software hates everyone, it's only right everyone
hates him back.
Please do so. Please feel free to sincerely,
passionately, unreservedly
hate Jason
and people like him.
Do keep it in mind. Anyway, goodbye for now and have a lovely
day. Goodbye, Mr. Card